I will answer injustice with justice I
will not become a page in someone else's
history book arguing
mother love Gardens I need to be moving
that we mustn't disappoint father
hey youtubers is Charlie and my Game of
Thrones Season 4 countdown continues
were within 30 days of the premiere and
they just posted a brand new trailer
with a bunch of new footage it also
included a very tall surprise that gives
us an idea for just how fast the plot is
going to be moving relative to the books
if you're finding me for the first time
I'm just doing a video countdown to the
season 4 premiere be sure to subscribe
to get everything
I'm even gonna do a special weekly
giveaway once the season starts so just
like my previous breakdowns this is
going to be a shot-for-shot analysis of
all the new footage in the trailer so
I'm gonna exclude everything that's been
in previous trailers careful for
spoilers if you don't want to know
anything about season 4 but let's go
starting off with a nice close-up shot
of widows wail Joffrey's new sword made
from smelting Ned Stark's Valyrian blade
ice then there's a new shot of Sansa and
during more of Joffrey's weapons
playtime which cuts to her recounting
the red wedding with new husband Tyrion
she has got a lot to cry about this
season next up is a scene of Ramsay snow
joining his father Roose Bolton as mad
as Roose seemed for aiding in the red
wedding he's still not as crazy as
Ramsay I always thought of the two of
them as like an evil version of Ned
Stark and Jon Snow here's more of Sansa
sleeping in a room that looks a lot like
a cell and it might as well be at least
Tyrion isn't making her sleep in his bed
then we finally get another nice long
scene with Oberyn Martell the red Viper
talking to Cersei about the value of
revenge for people who have not read the
books the scene is incredibly ironic
hopefully during the season they'll
explain why that is they are both
looking for revenge here is another
slightly better look at the city gate
submarine then Barristan Selmy
counseling Daenerys and it flows in
nicely into a speech of hers about
bringing justice to the city the shots
of the unsullied army are all repeated
from previous trailers but the next shot
this guy is brand new and somewhat
spoilery it's the Titan of Braavos the
place where Arya is dancing master Syrio
Forel and jaqen H'ghar are from remember
arias coin
it's a Braavosi coin I'll let you
rewatch the episode from season 2 if you
don't remember his instructions on how
she's supposed to use the coin and what
it does then there's another shot of
Daenerys Unseld
traveling they're trying to give us a
visual reminder of just how big her army
is I love the synchronicity of their
movements - it's actually grey worm
that's commanding them
Daenerys gives him orders and he gives
them to the unsullied then there's my
second favorite shot all three dragons
look at how much bigger drogon is then
rhaegal and Viserion they can hunt on
their own now especially drove on and it
becomes a huge problem as they get
bigger it's like trying to raise a wild
animal like a tiger in your home at some
point it's going to get out of control
and hurt or in Danny's case
flame-broiled someone remember the
dragons only eat charred meat extra
crispy
it's followed by another shot of
Daenerys trying to figure out how to be
a real queen now that she has all these
people depending on her she does not
want to disappoint them appropriately
followed by Tyrion standing trial in
front of his father Oberyn Martell and
mace Tyrell with a nice voiceover that
mirrors Danny's sentiment of not wanting
to disappoint his father Tywin then this
is an amazing shot of Tywin sitting on
the Iron Throne I just love the imagery
here the real power of Westeros
currently finally sitting in the visible
place of highest power this shot of the
girl with the bow confused a lot of
people but it's just one of Ramsay snows
girls from back when he was tormenting
Theon with sex she looks like she just
joined Ramsay on a hunt hopefully
they're not hunting Theon again next is
a new shot of brand crawling beyond the
wall trying to reach the three-eyed
raven the raven has been guiding brand
to him with visions then there's another
new shot of Oberyn Martell and his
paramour Ellaria sand totally enjoying
themselves in the HBO tradition and
finally on a new or at least better shot
of Jon Snow killing one of his former
wildling friends or comrades and arms
for a brief second I actually thought
that it looked like the same actor that
played Benjen stark in season one but
it's not so given that we have a few
more weeks before the season 4 premiere
it's likely that we'll get at least one
more trailer or a long featurette or
like a season recap like we did last
year a lot of you been requesting
specific videos for characters and house
histories but it likes it for my next
video do something just about the
dragons in Westeros let the history of
dragons in Westeros or at least in the
world
my next game of Thrones video though
will post tomorrow that'll be the QA
video for this video so you can ask me
any questions about the footage in the
trailer or anything about season 4 or
the first couple of episodes I've
already done a video about that
you can click here to watch that and
learn about wins the winner careful for
potential spoilers and you can click
here to get that Q&A video thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
high fives
you